unicorns are getting haircuts unicorns
are high-flying startups valued at over
a billion dollars but these companies
are seeing their valuations shrink when
they go public payment processors Square
took a three billion dollar IPO haircut
in 2015
cloud computing company Domo took over
1.7 billion dollars off the top in 2018
and the latest high-profile haircut came
this year from the Wii company weworks
parent company got a virtual buzz cut
lowering its valuation by 32 billion
dollars before the company withdrew its
IPO private investors have infused these
companies with cash betting they have
the potential to corner their markets
private valuations have become an
accepted yardstick for what these
companies are worth on the public market
but many investors believe these
valuations often overstate a firm's
likely true worth here's how that can
happen
private startups seeking investments
typically undergo a series of funding
rounds where investors usually venture
capital and private equity firms provide
cash in exchange for equity in the
company each new round of fundraising
sets a new valuation for the company
these valuations are usually based on
several factors including market size
revenue and management some investors in
analysts contend that the entire process
tends to carry a bias towards higher
prices because private markets are
filled almost exclusively by investors
who want their stakes to appreciate what
makes private markets different is that
they generally aren't subject to the
skepticism that's common in public
markets private funding is fueled by
optimism private investors unlike their
public counterparts typically are
constrained in their ability to sell
their stake in the company
and they can't bet against the stock by
selling it short there are a number of
factors that often make private market
valuations higher one popular way of
enticing investors is to offer them
preference shares securities that offer
perks above and beyond the ownership
state conferred by common stock
preference shares are often sold to
private round investors and are more
valuable than the common shares that are
typically sold in an IPO which helps
explain why private market valuations
often end up higher than public market
ones one common form of preference stock
sold in early funding rounds comes with
a liquidation preference which ensures
investors can get back whatever they
invested even if the company is sold at
a lower valuation a second preference
stock feature known as ratchet means
early investors can get additional
shares if the company does an IPO at a
lower price than the one at which they
bought in but during evaluation these
higher share classes are valued equally
to common stock even though they aren't
entitled to the same payoffs making
common stock appear more valuable than
it actually is the loading a company's
valuation Square was valued at six
billion dollars after its last round of
funding before going public but a study
found that special promises to late
round investors had inflated this
valuation the study calculated Square
was actually worth 2.2 billion dollars
close to the 2.6 billion dollar
valuation the company received for its
IPO a second reason for high valuations
is that private companies aren't subject
to the strict accounting practices that
public companies must use they are far
freer to present investors with
non-standard data that paints a rosier
picture of their financial health the
week company presented investors with
the metric called community adjusted
EBIT up it excluded big expenses
including some rent costs that would
usually be reported using generally
accepted accounting principles in
entering public markets companies agree
to report standard numbers based on
rules set by the SEC this enables
investors to more accurately compare
different firms finances
private market valuations can be a
useful data point for investors but the
rude awakening that firms like the Wii
company have received at times is making
many analysts and portfolio managers
increasingly skeptical of those big
numbers and forcing unicorns to take a
little or a lot off the top
you